All of the titles in this trailer are written
over these graphics, that resemble the Rorschach
test, which is used by psychologists to make
determinations about their patients based
on what they think they see first in the inkblots.
If you want to hear about the secret images
hidden in these inkblots then stick around
to the end of this video.
[Intro]
It’s a Decemberween miracle!
We got a new horror trailer on Decemberween.
What a generous gift from Peele.
Bring it in Peele.
Bring it in.
Alright, so this trailer starts off with the
family in the car, going to the beach and
listening to the song “I Got 5 on It”.
The kid asks what that means and the daughter
tells him about drugs, but then the father
tells him,
“It’s not about drugs, it’s a dope song.
Don’t do drugs.”
Now I’m not really an affianado on hip-hop,
unless we’re talking about lo-fi, so I had
to look this one up, and according my research
HE’S A LIAR.
The dad lied to his son.
About the meaning of this song.
But one of the things we’ve all been wondering
about Us before the trailer came out, was
if this one is going to be more of a straight
horror flick, or lean more towards comedy.
And it looks to be more on the serious side.
You’ve even got the son wearing a Jaws shirt,
and not only that, but wearing it to the beach.
He’s also got this Wolfman mask, I think
that’s what it is.
And the girl that we meet later is wearing
a Michael Jackson “Thriller” t-shirt,
which of course, has a music video known for
a depiction of a werewolf movie at the beginning.
Or maybe it’s most known for spawning this
meme now, but hopefully not.
So the son wanders off at the beach, encounters
a spooky guy who’s T-posing?
Dude you don’t need to be t-posing, you
already have blood on your hands.
But that’s actually not the only point in
the trailer that this happens, because the
son of the clone family is also seen doing
it.
See, even horror villains can do it for the
meme sometimes.
These dopplegangers of the original family,
take over the house and they appear to be
evil versions of the main characters.
But in addition to this family, there is also
a duplicate of this little girl, this boat
towards the beginning of the trailer is not
the same as the one seen later on in the dark,
and when they’re initially walking to the
beach, their long shadows represent a dark
version of themselves.
Since they have a dark version of themselves,
they may also be the next hit Nintendo franchise.
In fact, if you pause one minute and fifty-three
seconds into the trailer, you can clearly
see Mario is standing there, holding hands
with one of the doppelgangers.
This one’s called scissors Mario.
The hand-holding is also seen in this classroom
scene with a bunch of stick figures holding
hands on the chalkboard.
The handprints here below the chalkboard are
reminiscent of a Kindergarten art project
type of thing, but in this case they’re
all red, a reminder of the bloody-handed t-posing
guy from before.
We get it dude, we get it!
The other notable thing for me in this shot
is the woman holding these cutouts up like
bunny ears.
There are a lot of references to magic in
this trailer.
Rabbits are usually associated with magic,
because magicians are always trying to pull
a rabbit out of a hat for some reason.
The daughter’s got a rabbit on her shirt
at the lake, the doppelganger son sits like
a rabbit, there’s a hall full of rabbits,
and a fight that takes place in a room full
of caged rabbits.
The title card has a Rorschach test where
the middle white part looks like a rabbit’s
face looking straight at you.
We’ll come back to the rest of this though.
Another possible reason for all of the rabbits
other than the magic reference, is that rabbits
are known to quickly reproduce and the antagonists
of this movie seem to be reproductions of
the main family.
When the son wanders off, he goes towards
an attraction called Merlin’s Forest.
There is also a painting of a fox on the side
of that building, a natural predator of rabbits
and in this scene in the closet there is a
board game called Magic.
So those are the definite magic references,
and then there’s also a shot here of the
daughter on this cracked mirror, which makes
me think of people sometimes referring to
magic tricks as smoke and mirrors.
But the mirrors could have a different meaning,
since the doppelgangers are like mirror images
of the original characters.
And that’s where I’m gonna get into the
inkblot stuff.
Most of them are mirrored down the center.
I think this one looks like the son’s Wolfman
mask a little bit.
Maybe a little bit more like Chewbacca actually,
but they’re both pretty close.
In this one I see a skull.
And in this one I’m getting a creepy pair
of eyes with a mask.
Maybe a little Sub-Zero going on there.
The final title card is the most interesting.
I pointed out the rabbit already, but this
could also be interpreted as the handle of
the scissors seen throughout the trailer and
poster.
Then there are two faces looking outward,
but this is the only title graphic that doesn’t
have perfect symmetry.
Let me know what you saw in each of those
Rorschach tests though, those are always interesting
to hear what people saw.
Wait… hold on, hold on…
I think I see something....
Yes, it appears to say… subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.